around a billion people use instagram
every month
but the social media giant behind the
photo sharing app says it will hold off
on developing a version aimed
specifically at children under 13. i
still firmly believe that it's a good
thing to build a version of instagram
that's designed to be safe for tweens
but we want to take the time to talk to
parents and researchers and safety
experts and get to more consensus about
how to move forward
the retreat comes after an expose by the
wall street journal showing instagram's
corporate parent facebook conducted
research showing exposure to instagram
harmed teenagers especially girls
researchers reportedly wrote that 32
percent of teen girls said that when
they felt bad about their bodies
instagram made them feel worse
they also found significant numbers of
teens who reported suicidal feelings
cited instagram as a reason instagram
posts often show attractive people in
glamorous settings which may make users
feel inferior by contrast
so that invariably
people
come away from these online experiences
feeling that they will never measure up
feeling that they can never be pretty
enough or smart enough or charismatic
enough the 2019 presentation for company
executives reportedly declared we make
body image issues worse for one in three
teen girls
the research was reportedly cited in a
presentation to facebook ceo mark
zuckerberg last year
we do know senator ed markey of
massachusetts who will be holding
hearings on the matter on thursday wrote
that the leaked information was quote
appalling adding that facebook has
completely forfeited the benefit of the
doubt when it comes to protecting young
people and he called on the company to
abandon plans to launch a version of
instagram for kids under 13.
instagram says it is developing a
feature to actually suggest when young
people should stop viewing its content
that you could put your instagram on
pause for a period of time if you're in
a moment of vulnerability maybe you're
going through a breakup or you just
switched high schools facebook claims
the published internal documents were
taken out of context rob reynolds al
jazeera